how long do you think you're going to
live
60 70 80 years
okay we'll give you a hundred but don't
be fooled because many people die
way younger than that but let's say your
cutoff date
or death date is 100 years then what
have you prepared or thought about
what's to come next
now what's my purpose or goal in telling
you this
well it's to inspire you to think
deeper into the reality of this short
fleeting transitory life how many of us
have seen
friends or family members that you loved
or some that you even hated but now
they're gone
you've lost them doesn't this rattle
something inside of you to think
deeper into where they go we were just
arguing
joking laughing together
but now they're no more we somehow
think that we are going to live forever
in this life
as if science is going to develop a pill
that will extend our lives forever for
those of us who have been living for
some time
if you just look at the process of age
something very obvious when you just
look at some of the old pictures
of when you were young
but now we're becoming older
we were once full of strength but now we
are
going in reverse and becoming older and
weak
you get into a routine for many of us it
stays the same
wake up work work out
hang out sleep some eagerly awake the
weekends
just to be able to make it to the bars
or the nightclubs
where men lust over women like an animal
on the hunt for his prey and sadly
women go to these places putting
themselves on display
and becoming some horny dog's prey
waking up the next day with a nasty
hangover
feeling guilty and doing
the walk of shame and then
just to do the same thing the next
weekend
but this time you might have an std
is this what life is about
fulfilling one's desires at the expense
of losing
one's soul now your intuition tells you
this can't just be it baby mama drama
sports party play entertainment alcohol
drugs chasing all the material things
there has to be more to this life
than all of these superficial things an
ultimate goal
a true purpose to your existence to
why am i here on this earth
and where am i going when i die
you see my goal was to motivate you to
reflect
ponder and think to the reality of this
life
the reality of death and the common
sense
question that all of us should be asking
what is the purpose of my life why
am i here now it's up to you to do
something about it
thank you for listening subscribe
if you haven't already to the dean show
peace be with you